c'était une taxe destinée à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
la voilà aujourd'hui rempart pour sauver
l'union européenne de la crise du
coronavirus la taxe carbone pourrait
devenir une source de tension entre
l'union européenne et son partenaire
économique russe 8 janvier dernier la
commission européenne avait appelé à la
mise en place d'un mécanisme d'inclusion
carbone aux portes de l'europe objectif
atteindre une économie neutre pour le
climat d'ici à 2050
ce mécanisme inédit de pollueur payeur
est donc destiné aux pays exportant vers
l'union européenne sans avoir pris de
mesures visant à réduire leurs émissions
de co2 acier ciment verre ou encore
chimie sont concernés une mesure à
double impact destiné par la même
occasion à dissuader les entreprises
européennes de délocaliser leur
production hors de l'union aussi
longtemps qu'un grand nombre de
partenaires internationaux ne
partageront pas la même ambition que
lieu le risque de fuite de carbone sera
présent soit parce que la production est
transféré de l'ue vers d'autres pays
moins ambitieux en matière de réduction
des émissions soit parce que les
produits lieux sont remplacés par des
produits importés à plus forte intensité
de carbone
mais voilà qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne semble avoir changé son fusil
d épaule pour surmonter la crise du
coronavirus elle annonce un plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros dont
les fonds proviennent d'un emprunt
inédits comme 1,28 taxe impopulaire
auprès des populations voilà la taxe
carbone soudainement devenu source de
financement mais il faudra bien que
quelqu'un la paye et ce sont les
partenaires commerciaux de l'union qui
devront s'en acquitter
une annonce qui inquiète notamment la
russie qui tire une grande partie de ses
revenus de ses exportations
d'hydrocarbures et de matières premières
notamment vers l'europe moscou voilà une
mesure injuste voire incompatibles avec
les règles du commerce international
en cas d'application de cette mesure
sans aucune restriction la taxe carbone
européenne contredirait les normes de
certains accords internationaux en
vigueur dont la convention cadre des
nations unies sur les changements
climatiques qui interdit d'utiliser les
mesures de lutte contre le changement
climatique pour limiter la compétitivité
internationale
pour l'heure
bruxelles demeure inflexible nous avons
cette ambition du green deal ceux qui
n'auront pas cette ambition ils peuvent
venir sur le marché intérieur mais
devront payer le différentiel c'est
normal est absolument régulier si jamais
cet accord n'est pas valide et on
proposera nous mêmes notre mécanisme et
les vingt-sept tomberont d'accord
ce protectionnisme vert européen
intervient alors que les américains font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour mettre en
échec le projet nord stream 2 qui
prévoit d'accroître les livraisons de
gaz entre la russie et l'allemagne
pourtant achevée à 95%
le chantier dont la construction a été
lancée en 2018 devait être achevée cette
année pour une mise en service en 2021
reliant la russie à l'allemagne par la
mer baltique nord stream ii est censé
doubler son petit frère dans scream 1
lancé lui en 2012
menaçant de sanctions toute entreprise
travaillant sur la construction du
gazoduc
washington a déclaré vouloir prémunir
les européens contre une dépendance
vis-à-vis du gaz russe
omettant de préciser bien sûr qu'il
s'agit surtout d'aider les producteurs
américains de gaz de schiste bien plus
onéreux à se positionner sur le marché
européen
ce à quoi nous nous attendons c'est que
ce qui participeront à ce projet seront
soumis à un examen pour d'éventuelles
sanctions prises en étau entre le
protectionnisme européen et les
sempiternel sanctions américaines
l'économie russe est mise à rude épreuve
alors que vladimir poutine s'est donné
pour objectif d'augmenter les
exportations russes d'au moins 70% d'ici
à 2030